in this video for at least 30 seconds a
security guard presses his arm against
tobias white's neck
they're restraining him in a nightclub
in magaluf after he allegedly assaulted
a doorman
but it's this handling by bouncers and
the police which tobias's family believe
led to his death
i've always looked
to the
police system to protect
i want those
who are accountable
for what i believe is the murder of my
son
to be brought to justice for it
after being rejected for a taxi because
he was topless his family say he
returned to the club and that's when
trouble ensued
they gave him another beating and it was
ruthless it was it was getting muslims
at the time
chris was there on the night of july
25th and says tobias a man he'd never
met before was brutally beaten by police
the police they've took him up the
stairs semi-conscious head rolling back
when he's walking up the stairs and then
they fall into the floor
and next thing you know that straight
away there's three officers right on top
of them
maybe
five minutes later there was eight
officers win them especially on the neck
and on the body area
and it was very clear that
it wasn't like what was happening
but in a statement the spanish police
said mr white was expelled from the
nightclub by security for his aggressive
behavior and the guardian civil had to
reduce him due to his resistance and
aggressiveness
they added apparently his body had a
combination of three different types of
drugs and alcohol
yeah he was screaming and now he
nothing
outside the club police and then
paramedics gave tobias cpr
for five days mr white lay in hospital
unconscious before his life support
machine had to be switched off
despite several attempts the boomerang
nightclub wouldn't provide us with a
comment but the foreign office said
they're supporting the family who are
now trying to get tobias white's body
back to the uk
but all i can do
is fight
and
help
to get those who have done this to him
to be held accountable
spanish judicial authorities will now
try to piece together the sequence of
events that led to this british man's
death they are answers the family of
much-loved tobias are desperate for
insane rasheed sky news